survivor castaway Zeke Smith outed as
transgender by fellow contestant jet
foreigner there is deception here why
haven't you told anyone you're
transgender that's the moment that
enraged several contestants and host
Jeff Probst during Wednesday's episode
of game changers Varner thought he was
going home so he decided to reveal one
last piece of information in hopes of
saving himself what I'm showing is a
deception but that's personal it has
nothing to do with you guys so wrong we
are you to bring that up I'm not using
that as anything like a lot Barner was
lambasted by the entire tribe he
insisted that he supports transgender
rights and had no ill intentions but
still profusely apologized my conscious
is in pain I feel horrible I didn't
think that would be the reaction I
thought he was proud and out and loud
about it and I did not understand no
surprise here a Varner was voted off
unanimously as for Zeke he handled the
situation calmly with class I am a
changed stronger better man today than I
was then so you know what
Varner was really not cool like you know
I'm fine
[Music]
you